luckily I'm kind of good at this kind of
stuff I don't want to get sent home
early today so I'm gonna do everything I
can to win so by any means necessary has
taken on new meaning on The Bachelor if
you want to stay on the running to
become Farmer Chris's bride end put on a
wedding dress and start sprinting in the
mud losers go home and the winner gets a
romantic night out here's a sneak peak
of Monday's episode hey ladies who likes
it dirty it'd be hard to be with a woman
that's afraid to get dirty at least a
little bit dirty you know they gotta
have a little bit of a toughness too
heavy we're calling this the dirtiest
bachelor challenge ever mud is not
something I'm afraid of so this is this
is right up my alley I'm a farmer and
I've been been around dirt my whole
entire life
okay so Prince farming is down for the
mud run but what about the ladies I
don't know that you can ever prepare to
do a mud race and a wedding dress oh my
gosh it is hot out here
it is a scorcher but I'm excited I'm
ready to get down and dirty
I bet when I'm done this is gonna be a
brown dress and not a white one eye on
the prize eye on the prize
getting a little nervous and thing you
might have to do a little ripping and
tying in knots and rigging my dress
because they definitely have an
advantage with the shorter dresses I
help them mud run and turning to mud
rustling he might like that but I don't
know that I like that the ladies tugged
on their tool and we were behind the
scenes catching the sprinting splashing
and oh this crazy rope obstacle
contraption that's about 90 degrees it
feels like we're gonna run through a
bunch of mud and and kind of test our
our endurance together it's pretty much
the saddest thing ever if we lose we
have to go home and the winner gets to
go on the one-on-one date with Chris ah
I mean there's so much at stake and it
looks like love is in the air there's
definitely an attraction I mean look at
him
he's a the sexiest farmer in America
right I'm optimistic that the my future
wife could be in this group they're all
so great that it's you know it's hard to
even really know exactly which one is
right for me looking to get a lot more
time with them to sort that out